we recently interviewed Street
epistemology Anthony Magna Bosco on the
show and one of the people he mentioned
in terms of who he learned from was
Peter Boghossian and we actually
interviewed Peter Boghossian on the show
in February of 2014 about three years
ago and that was a really really good
interview about his techniques and his
work so I think it'll be interesting to
go back today for our classic interview
- when I spoke to Peter Boghossian and
this is actually somebody I'd be
interested in having back on the show
because so much has happened in the
world of critical thinking and
rationality in the last three years but
for today we'll go back to my
conversation with Peter Boghossian from
February of 2014 I'm joined by dr. Peter
Boghossian he's a full-time faculty
member in Portland State University's
philosophy department he's also author
of the best-selling book a manual for
creating atheists first question just to
kind of give us a little bit of context
dr. Boghossian is did you grow up
religious my dad used to bring me to go
meet up at altars but it was just he
liked staying in the choir and I like to
run around I never took it seriously
Catholic and my father was before talks
and he converted to Catholicism from my
grandmother so what was your first kind
of line of thinking along religion was
it the type of thing where your first
influence was from parents did you
immediately take two the first ideas you
were presented with or did you resist
them understood so when you talk to
people who are believers do you find
that your conversations tend to go and
in your book you talk about whether it's
the bank teller or people you meet in
the street whoever it is you like to
engage them about the religiosity do you
find that your conversations with
believers whatever their religious
persuasion maybe go more along the lines
of discussing whether their specific
religion and the teachings of their
religion are literally provable or true
or are the conversations broader when it
comes to religion than their specific
teachings I actually never almost never
talk about religion or specific
properties in the Vedic tradition and I
always always 100% of the time talk
about how people know what it is that
they claim to know so the first thing I
do is I try to figure out what what
people think that they know what they're
claiming what their knowledge claims are
and then I try to figure out by asking
questions
how do they mean how do you think they
know what they know okay so then when
what we're really talking about here is
as you talked about the Socratic method
of questioning and we can probably also
talk about the basic fundamentals of
epistemology including Aristotle and
Rene Descartes so when you engage people
along these lines do you find most
believers will engage with you along the
terms that you've kind of set or do you
come up against the brick wall of sorts
where you get to a point where they say
well I don't need to follow your
rationale because I know that my God is
God and therefore I can circumvent the
entire line of reasoning you're trying
to impose on me as it may be probably
won't believe but it's totally sincere I
almost don't get that I almost never get
that because the overwhelming majority
of people with whom I speak are sincere
and it's not everybody but yeah they're
sincere and they think either they have
good reasons for believing what they
believe or if we can suss that out what
in the beginning of the conversation
that they're pretending to know things
they don't know and if almost never
speak to you I mean certainly you get
someone who says well that's my faith
I'm just going to leave the matter well
I mean there's no question about that
and so and the creaminess I talk about a
lot of brand civility introduced courses
when if you know somebody who has faith
or taste in the world or places trust
Jesus or Zeus or what have you that
these these really are conversations
that you can have without people
freaking out or being upset at each
other or screaming but just just
parenthetically just as an aside the
question and answers from my talks are
posed in a Lana Deva talk at a preferred
candidate and you could see that was how
simple those those were the question is
but no when you listen to that this
directly answers your question you don't
really you know find very much so let's
I like this idea of being able to
discuss these things in a civil way
because some people I talk to about
whether it's religion or politics or
anything it really doesn't matter I'm
able to have what clearly is a civil
conversation regardless of whether we
agree or disagree at the same time and
it seems to happen a lot with with more
religious individuals that I interview
on the show me merely questioning
whether the story they believe as
whether it's the story of creation or as
what God has done specifically or not
done me questioning that in any way is
immediately offensive and I've worked
relatively hard over a period of many
years to find a way to ask questions
that really make someone defend their
beliefs which I think they should have
to without being offensive to them and
some would say well listen David when
the guest tells you they're offended by
you saying you don't believe Jesus was
really born to a virgin died and came
back to life when they say they're
offended by that it's it's a cover right
it's because they can't really back it
up with actual fact while the believers
will say it's deeply offensive because
they sincerely hold these beliefs I
honestly don't know how to get around
that how can you have a conversation
where you question these beliefs without
being offensive to individuals who
consider themselves very devout your
attention nothing to you so if somebody
says that they're offended by something
and that happens occasion occasionally
in chapter 4 my book excuse me I give
they there are ways to ask questions and
set the tone of the conversation in fact
this is one of the primary researchers I
haven't I ask those questions to that
well don't come possess it and they're
more like two
have discussions the people's more the
reasons they become offended is because
they don't have enough evidence for what
they believe like your Marcin so okay
okay but we did before the show we're
trying to stop the audio equipment if I
needed hey you know I don't go to Skype
but then look back and you said what
computer your are you want I said on my
maps and how do you know you're looking
at right houses MacBook Pro he did no
reason to be upset with that people
become obsessed because there's a
differential there's a difference
between what does they have faith in
something if the Walker that means I do
not have sufficient evidence to believe
in something is part of this using a
method of questioning and asking
questions rather than telling someone
that's part of it and part of it is
sincerity you have to always be sincere
when you ask questions and you have to
ask questions because you want to know
the answer and coupled with that you
must do and this is the thing that takes
a lot of work it's an attitude with the
tune of the part of the questioner so
you have to go to these conversations
Jing literally thinking and only if you
can you only think but okay I'm gonna
give this person the benefit of the
doubt why is it in academic speak it's
called hermeneutic of charity I'm gonna
give them the benefit of the doubt
why is something this you know maybe
they know something I don't know
so what we're trying to do is to not
question their conclusions and to figure
out and in the book I give a template
and ways specifically and exactly how
you do this how to figure out what it is
they claim to know if it's legitimate
and if it can be said two words belief
and it could even blow holes no yeah
that's the case the name something you
know indicated after that people the
last thing I want to touch on in the
limited time we have is this idea of
sometimes I will talk to atheist and
agnostics and they are very proactive in
their belief that there is no God and
there could be no God whether others
more like me say I'm not against the
idea of a God in principle I just
haven't found any evidence so far that
makes me believe one exists where do you
find yourself to be on
spectrum ah and then I have one more
thing to just comment about the last
question you asked me I finally tell I
find he's in the book I am you not I
find it like you I guess we had longer
Tommy would slash those terms out but it
I do not think that there's to secure
evidence to warrant police either in a
natural realm or in a God however if I
referred give insufficient evidence to
warrant belief then I would believe as
dr. Peter Boghossian mentioned the book
is a manual for creating atheist he is a
full-time faculty member in Portland
State University's philosophy department
really great to have you on I encourage
everybody to check out the book thank
you for your time